bonsoir france 19 écossaise après 80
minutes de jeu sous la pluie match
violent viril mais correct
ces images étonnantes de joueurs qui en
souriant échangent leur maillot et se
serrent la main en souriant
même ceux qui ont perdu même les
écossais nous allons revenir dans un
instant sur cette victoire deuxième
victoire de l'équipe de france dans le
tournoi des cinq nations
mais avant toute chose rendons aux
césars la place qui leur appartient
c'est à dire la première ce soir puisque
événements de l'année cinématographique
c'est dans quelques minutes sur antenne
2 en direct de la salle pleyel que nous
connaîtrons les noms de ceux qui vont
recevoir la plus haute récompense du
cinéma français une récompense dont le
symbole une petite statuette argenté duo
sculpteur césar et près de vous france
rof athlètes et doré mais j'ai prévenu à
la présidente de la soirée et jeanne
moreau après jean gabin et lino ventura
elle préside ce soir et je crois qu'elle
n'aura aucun mal à faire son discours de
présidente
car depuis un an elle ne fais qu'écrire
oui en effet mais je suis très bien vrai
que georges cravenne le perdre
césar est pensé à moi mon président et
ses soirées et puis je suis si heureuse
d'être de nouveau en france
et j'aime tellement les acteurs que
c'est une grande joie pour moi vous avez
quitté la fosse par amour et par mariage
par amour et par mariage et je reviens
par amour est un mariage avec la france
et vous allez tourner un film qui peut
être l'année prochaine a nommé pour le
meilleur qui me va je l'espère capacit
dans la nous il ya deux ans vous étiez
nommé comme meilleur acteur de second
plan et meilleur acteur les premiers
puis vous n'avez pas une et 16 ans
c'était le bon temps
non vous avez trouvé le moyen d'avoir
fait statuette dans les mains vous êtes
le maître de cérémonie là je me suis dit
oh moi je les touche une fois dans mon
existence
mais ça doit être difficile quand même
de présenter un spectacle avec ses pairs
vous avez préparé des shows n'autorise
aucune chance mais
le trac mots ça va mais on a préparé et
certaines choses mais je peux pas vous
dire encore maintenant si ce qu'on a
préparé ça va marcher ou non donc ça
c'est celle aventure dalo grimace oui
j'ai préparé des mini oui oui vous
voulez que je vous ans a su nous donner
un message est toujours ma valise à
munich
oui oui les questions qu'on puisse vous
a concoté césar c'est tout simplement il
n'y a pas de trucage un nom de trucage
il ya 15 cents personnes qui votent
expliqué jane
oui absolument se sont tous les gens de
la profession qui ont voté sous
enveloppe scellée qui sont gardés par
annie sié et au fur et à mesure de la
cérémonie les deux clochers
les emplois seront couverts et à ce
qu'on voit là on annoncera les gagnants
c'est le problème ça a été loin de
l'organisation de cette série c'est que
comme on ne sait pas qui sera vainqueur
on peut rien prévoir on est obligé
d'avoir d'état d'extrait de tout le
monde sous les mains pour pouvoir les
envoyer au moment voulu
c'est exactement pour les oscars réponse
donc à 20h30 dans moins de 30 minutes
maintenant sur antenne 2 en direct
merci jeanne moreau merci france roche
merci victor lanoux vos rugby donc
maintenant la france a battu l'ecosse
cet après midi à murrayfield par 19 à 16
un match qui s'est déroulé la plupart du
temps sous une pluie battante le petit
frisson qui a parcouru le dos des
supporters français à la mi temps on
n'était pas due aux intempéries mais
plutôt à l'inefficacité du quinze
tricolore menait alors 13 à 4
heureusement un match de rugby
ces deux périodes et comme devant
l'angleterre au parc des princes
les français ont repris l'aventage peu à
peu pendant les 40 dernières minutes
la première mi temps a été plutôt
malheureuse pour les joueurs du quinze
de france
déjà menés depuis la 10e minute sur
pénalité du capitaine écossais morgane
les français commettent cette action une
énorme erreur qui va coûter cher gourdon
prend son temps se fait qu'on ferait et
finalement chez del mar canesso à ce
moment-là l'ecosse mène déjà 7 à 0
encore une erreur des français sur cette
action à la 36e minute à gears intercalé
est bloquée regroupement pour les
écossais la balle va sortir pour irvine
qui tape à suivre
avez vous va-t-il arrivé le premier sur
ce ballon oui mais finalement irvine a
bien suivi la balle et plonge dans l'en
but français marquant un essai
supplémentaire et se blessant par la
même occasion irvine veut quitter le
terrain
heureusement juste avant la mi-temps
gavillon réduit la marque sur cette
action il tape à suivre
mauvaise réception de macaques et galion
marque l'essai de l'espoir
13 1 4 pour la france l'europe
nous sommes maintenant de ces mutants
sur pénalité à gears a réduit l'écart
dès la reprise 13 à 7
la france n'est plus qu'à la portée d'un
essai transformé le voici cet essai on
le sent venir
et finalement sur cette action des
avants français cette ag qui va percuter
la défense écossaise et qui va marquer
en force l'essai de l'espoir
à gears réussir à ce moment là pour la
première fois du match
la france prend l'avantagé 16 à 3 mais
les zips aussi beaucoup d'espoirs sur
cette égalisation heureusement pour la
france à gears en dernière minute passe
la pénalité
seul qui donne la victoire à la france
19 à 16 la deuxième victoire de la
france dans le tournoi des six nations
le quinze de france qui ce soir occupe
la première place du tournoi et puis
toujours pour le tournoi des cinq
nations le pays de galles a battu
l'angleterre à twickenham cet après-midi
par 9 à 6 on réduit encore dans un match
comptant pour la coupe d'europe cette
fois l'équipe de france b a battu
l'italie 31 à 9
enfin pour clore ce panorama sportif de
la journée sachez qu'en football en
première division
metz a battu le paris saint germain par
2 buts à 1 et 3 a battu sochaux 1 à 0
avec l'eau d'ailleurs dans le dernier
journal vous donnera les résultats de la
soirée des matches de national 1 en
basket ball
il faut savoir aussi qu'en ski
l'allemande maria et pleut est devenue
championne du monde en slalom géant ce
matin à garmisch partenkirchen
marié à épeler devenue championne du
monde de slalom géant
elle devance la suissesse lice marie
moreau et la grande championne
autrichienne mary mother paul à la
quatrième place on trouve irene pelé la
soeur de maria qui n'a pu confirmer son
meilleur temps de la première manche
les françaises serra et paul n ont déçu
une nouvelle fois à part la médaille de
bronze serra au combiné elle ne me
ramène rien de garmisch partenkirchen
cela faisait bien longtemps que les
français n'avaient pas ramené de
médaille d'un championnat du monde il
est bien loin le temps de portillo et de
sa pluie de médailles
à noter que dans les dix premières de
soasta l'homme on trouve deux
ressortissants du liechtenstein pin qui
ne compte que 26 mille habitants en
france il y en a 50 millions le travail
manuel a été oublié en france depuis 100
ans
actuellement nous nous occupons de le
réhabiliter a déclaré monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing en assistant aux
cérémonies de clôture de la deuxième
semaine du travail manuel organisée au
grand palais à paris aujourd'hui notre
objectif a également précisé le chef de
l'état est de réaliser d'ici 1985
l'égalité de rémunération entre les
travailleurs manuels et les autres il
s'agit d'ailleurs non seulement d'un
problème de rémunération mais aussi de
considérations président de la
république s'est félicité de l'évolution
moderne du travail manuel qui va faire
disparaître progressivement le travail à
la chaîne et précisément jean-marc il
use et aller enquêter pour nous sur une
expérience très particulière tenté dans
l'usiné de la française de mécanique
près de lens ce n'est pas seulement le
cadre que l'on a voulu changer améliorer
mais également la notion de travail à la
chaîne dans cette usine
ce n'est peut-être pas encore les os de
l'an 2000 mais ce ne sont plus les temps
modernes de charlie chaplin regardez
4000 employés 2500 moteurs par jour 210
tonnes de métal coulé quotidiennement
et pourtant vous chercherez en vain la
française de mécanique
les cheminées noirâtre ou la laideur
uniforme de l'ancien pays minier on veut
montrer ici que l' usine de demain
peut-être plus humaine en combattant la
monotonie non seulement dans
l'architecturé mais aussi dans le
travail est particulièrement là où il
est souvent le moins qualifiés et le
plus déshumanisant sur les chaînes de
montage
premier objectif rendre l'opérateur la
plupart du temps à nos os ou un
tributaire du pas de chaîne c'est à dire
de la vitesse à laquelle les pièces
défilent devant lui pour cela on a
découpé la longue chaîne traditionnelle
en plusieurs mini chaîne autonome
préparation des pièces habillage dans
des serres dans un deuxième temps à
l'intérieur de chaque chaîne on a
regroupé les opérations pour permettre à
chaque l'ouvrier d'accomplir une tâche
plus longue donc plus variés
on n'a pas toujours le même travail ce
qui est bien au fait du tibia sur chaîne
que par ailleurs aussi bien à travailler
sur les culasses sur les rampes faire un
montage
c'est comme ça qu'on apprend bien le
travail pas moins pénible mais plutôt
plus intéressant aux cabrioles mais
plutôt une évolution de travailler et
qu'on est ensemble
cette course avait les signaux de choses
mais on fait quoi ce qu'on a voulu
éliminer c'est aussi toutes les 40
secondes cette opératrice répète un
nombre limité de veste au rythme de
défilement de son chariot sur la chaîne
d'habillage désormais en aval sur cette
chaîne on effectue des tâches dans richy
dont la durée a atteint 7 et même 13
minutes 13 minutes
c'est déjà la norme pour tous dans le
nouvel atelier gît sur le moteur de la
r21 est ce là aussi efforts
architectural et enrichissement des
tâches sont liés ici quatre mini chaîne
d'habillage sont répartis dans un
atelier en forme de h
entre ces chaînes des stocks tampons
pour stabiliser l'écoulement de la
production et permettre à chaque chaîne
de travailler à son propre rythme
une source d'autonomie supplémentaire
qui permet la constitution d' équipe où
chacun va réaliser non plus une mais la
totalité des opérations nécessaires ici
le montage du bloc cylindres l'opérateur
n'est plus attaché son chariot il peut
en contrôler la marche à chaque stade de
son travail voilà le bloc cylindres est
prêt il va partir vers la zone de
stockage grâce à cette zone tampon
l'équipe chargée de la suite des
opérations que travailler à un rythme
différent de celle qui la précède
premiers résultats pour le chef de
l'atelier gym il travaille dans
l'automobile depuis 17 ans la création
d'un esprit d équipe synonyme de
responsabilités donc de qualité alors
niveau qualité il s'en sort beaucoup
plus
arrivé avec dans ce contexte là que
s'ils travaillent en micro opération il
a un engagement de sa personne ici ne
sont produit lui même et tous les mois
on a des réunions où on fait un point
qualité où il donne ses résultats donc
il connaît sa position reste la position
de son groupe
contrairement à ce qui se passe ailleurs
tel que 10000 et bakhit et enchaîne avec
peut-être le nez sur le mur y avait de
grandes chances qu'ils se sentaient
complètement embrigader tandis qu'ici
maintenant ils ont un horizon qui est
beaucoup plus ouvert et une possibilité
d'évolution
attention des syndicats il ne faut pas
confondre innovation et évolution la cgt
parle de tape-à-l'oeil
le nouvel atelier il est vrai ne sont
pas encore en pleine production
elle craint vie l'augmentation sournoise
décadence de son côté la cfdt
majoritaire
sans condamner le système réserve encore
son jugement
est-ce qu'à réellement enrichissement
lorsqu'un ouvrier au lieu de faire mille
fois les mêmes gestes fait 200 fois cinq
gestes différents donc on voudrait faire
croire aux gens que l'on leur tâche est
enrichi alors que bombe en fin de
journée la pénibilité est la même alors
s'il est trop tôt pour affirmer que la
française de mécanique c'est déjà lusine
de demain s'enchaînent des 100 go s il
reste qu'elle représente déjà une nette
pure avec le passé c'est un premier pas
important
raymond barre et françois mitterrand au
palais des congrès aujourd'hui par
rencontre toutefois entre le premier
ministre et le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
ils participaient tous deux à des
réunions différentes même si dans un
certain sens les sujets abordés au cours
de ces réunions pourraient se rejoindre
raymond barre a assisté au congrès
national du mouvement ethic entreprises
de taille humaine industriel et
commercial
françois mitterrand lui participait au
forum débat sur les cadres et le
socialisme pas question d'abolir les
avantages acquis a expliqué le leader
socialiste en invitant les cadres à
engager le dialogue avec la gauche
il y a comme une sorte d' absence des
cadres dans la responsabilité civile
à quoi cela est il dû ce n'est pas dû au
manque d'intérêt je crois que c'est dû
au manque de temps à la façon dont le
rôle du cadre est considéré dans
l'entreprise il y consacrer beaucoup
d'heures par jour plus d'heures encore
qui ne convient en porte ce dossier fait
corps avec l'entreprise et se trouve en
somme de lui même écarté de tous les
autres motifs d'intérêt hors de
l'entreprise comme l'est la vie de la
cité
la commune le département et la vie au
niveau 2 des assemblées parlementaires
faut corriger cela deux étages plus bas
et trois heures plus tard le premier
ministre prononcer le discours de
clôture du congrès de l'éthique
mouvement d entreprise à taille humaine
et rappelait les dernières mesures
prises par le gouvernement en faveur des
cadres en ce qui concerne le
gouvernement il articule sa politique
autour de deux orientations simple la
première c'est de reconnaître le rôle
d'impulsion qui revient aux cadres dans
la vie des entreprises
c'est la raison pour laquelle après une
concertation fructueuse
le gouvernement a fait adopter au cours
de la dernière session par le parlement
une loi permettant une meilleure
concertation entre direction et cadres
de l'entreprise c'est un premier pas le
gouvernement a de l'émission à monsieur
de l'ouvrier d'examiner les moyens de
faciliter l'accès des travailleurs et
principalement de la maîtrise de
l'encadrement à l'actionnariat dans leur
propre entreprise
monsieur de l'ouvrier dois me remettre
dans les jours qui viennent son rapport
et nous veillerons à en tirer tous les
enseignements et en tirer toutes les
applications qui nous paraîtront
ultime un nouveau sondage dans
l'actualité de ce week-end il est publié
par le quotidien le matin et aussi par
l'hebdomadaire le nouvel observateur
si les français avaient voté aujourd'hui
4 février à 60,18 la gauche leur est en
porte et avec 19 sièges d'avancé à
l'assemblée nationale la gauche
obtiendrait 51% des voix contre 40,5 à
la majorité ce qui lui donnerait 255
sièges contre 236 à l'actuelle majorité
bienheureux week-end pour le franc la
fermeture du marché des changes marque
en effet un terme à la baisse de la
monnaie française par rapport aux
devises étrangères dans la matinée
d'ailleurs monsieur raymond barre a
souligné une nouvelle fois la nécessité
de la confiance en matière monétaire
jean claude mongeau et jean françois
kahn n'ont pas manqué eux dans notre
magazine samedi et demi de demander à
leurs invités yves guéna le délégué
général du rpr
quelles pourraient être les conséquences
sur le franc de la situation économique
de l'arrivée de la gauche au pouvoir
après les prochaines élections
ces élections dont certains disent
qu'elle ramènerait le chaos économique
certains ne serait-il pas tenter de
montrer dès maintenant quel genre de
conséquences à pourrait avoir en pesant
sur le franc par exemple si on le
faisait ce serait misérables et s'il y
en avait la preuve je condamnerai ce qui
serait ce là dont le franc est
actuellement attaquer c'est vrai il perd
des points c'est vrai pourquoi parce que
il ya probablement une inquiétude sur
l'avenir de l'économie française et
aussi je me dis carrément parce que une
monnaie traduit l'état d'une économie or
il est vrai que l'économie française du
fait de la crise n'est pas dans une
situation excellente
unia est optimiste que
que certains nomment non non je
considère que la france n'est pas sortie
de la crise sur votre agenda de
télévision pour la semaine prochaine
vous noté deux rendez vous lundi 21h30
sur antenne 2 un débat spécial élections
gaston defferre christian bonnet et puis
mercredi prochain à 20h30 cartes sur
table jacques chirac interrogé par
jean-pierre elkabbach et alain duhamel
le pdg de manufrance monsieur jacques
petit a démissionné ce matin en raison
des difficultés financières de
l'entreprise de saint-etienne monsieur
fonvieille l'un des principaux
actionnaires privés de l'entreprise le
remplace pas ou peu de courrier dans la
région parisienne aujourd'hui une grève
des postiers qui va d'ailleurs s'étendre
à la province après l'appel lancé par la
cgt et la cfdt pour protester contre
l'évacuation par la police du centre de
tri de créteil
tous les centres de tri de paris de la
région parisienne ont été touchés
aujourd'hui par la grèce le mouvement
s'est étendu à plusieurs centres de
chèques postaux et d'exploitation des
télécommunications nombreux débrayages
également en province notamment à lyon
clermont ferrand et montpellier outre la
réintégration de l'agent licencié à
créteil les syndicats posent un certain
nombre de revendications avec en premier
lieu la fin du vacarme ya les ptt emploi
en effet 6000 vacataires qui sont
embauchés pour des durées limitées à un
salaire de 1350 francs pour 120 heures
mensuelles augmentation des effectifs et
des salaires
quels sont les autres revendications de
la cgt et de la cfdt qui appellent leurs
adhérents à amplifier leur action et a
manifesté lundi matin devant le
ministère des ptt la sphère des deux
nouveaux otages au tchad
nous ne sommes pas responsables a
expliqué aujourd'hui officiellement le
frolinat le front national de libération
du tchad
ce ne sont donc pas ces sommes que vous
voyez ici en armes qui ont enlevé les
deux jeunes européens le français
christian maes et son compagnon suisse
andré qu mérignies pour le frolinat ce
sont des vagabond errant des bandits qui
sont les ravisseurs
en fait on peut penser qu'il s'agit tout
simplement de quelques dissidents du
frolinat une dizaine d'hommes peut-être
qu'ils ont leurs bases au nigeria de
toute façon cela ne va pas simplifier la
tâche de la croix-rouge à qui les
autorités françaises et suisses ont
demandé donc d'intervenir pour sa part
monsieur claude chayenne le diplomate du
quai d'orsay qui avait négocié déjà pour
les otages du polisario monsieur coach
ier a reçu aujourd'hui les parents de
l'étudiant enlevé au chat
la rencontre au sommet carter sadate
c'est top secrète
même les journalistes américains ne
savent pas ce que se disent en ce moment
les présidents égyptiens et américains à
camp david
la rencontre a lieu en tête à tête même
les proches conseillers des deux chefs
d'état n'ont pas participer aux
conversations
la seule chose que l'on puisse savoir
exactement c'est l'état d'esprit dans
lequel le président sadate s'est rendu
aux états unis
pierre serra du caire il s'agit pour lui
de convaincre non seulement jimmy carter
mais encore le lobby juif américain
d'exercer une pression suffisante sur le
gouvernement de menahem begin pour qu'il
accepte une déclaration de principe sur
l'évacuation des territoires arabes
occupés et sur l'avenir des palestiniens
pour l'egypte s'est en effet c'est
seulement une déclaration de cette
nature qui pourra sauver le processus de
paix en permettant une reprise sérieuse
des négociations israélo égyptienne
si on se reporte aux travaux de la
commission bilatérale militaire qui
vient de terminer au caire son deuxième
round
on se rend compte que personne d'un côté
comme de l'autre ne crois vraiment qu
une décision déterminante puisse sortir
de ces échanges entre militaires ces
conversations ne sont utiles
actuellement que dans la mesure où elle
prolonge un dialogue qui n'est pas tout
à fait un dialogue de sourds mais un
dialogue au cours duquel on ne pourra
pas s'entendre tant que n'auront pas été
clarifiées sur le plan politique les
bases de discussion et bien c'est cette
clarification qu'anouar el sadate va
tenter d'obtenir de washington au cours
de ce voyage qu'il entreprend qui le
mènera aussi dans différentes capitales
européennes dont paris
on est prudent sinon sceptiques ici sur
les chances de succès du raïs on estime
généralement que les américains s'ils ne
sont pas décidés à répondre pleinement
aux égyptiens trouveront un nouveau
cadre de négociation comportant moins de
risque de rupture plus sûr donc plus
lent aussi et en tout cas moins
spectaculaire
c'est non seulement l'egypte et le
président sadate mais également les
états unis qui ont été vivement
critiquées au cours du sommet d'alger
qui s'est terminée aujourd'hui sommet de
la fermeté nous semble-t-il pour la
première fois les pays arabes qui
n'accepte pas les initiatives du
président sadate vont prendre un certain
nombre de décisions concrètes
gérard ce bac d'alger le président de la
république algérienne monsieur
comédienne a tenu à donner un caractère
de sérieux et de travail offertes à
cette conférence du groupe la fermeté
selon deux séances parfois très longues
heures s'est efforcé de rapprocher des
points de vue parfois très divergents on
peut dire ce soir qu'il a en partie
réussi et que ce sommet débouche sur un
résultat concret la présence du
président kadhafi a renforcé le poids de
cette conférence pour le premier point
était bien sûr de condamner totalement
l'initiative du président sadate et bien
fait remarquer ne pouvait parler ni au
nom de la série tout nom des
palestiniens
le président kaczynski a demandé à
monsieur arafat chef de l'olp et à qui
l'on reproché de garder des contacts
avec le président égyptien condamné
clairement l'initiative du guerre
monsieur arafat casser les rangs de
l'ump se resserre que l'un des durs
parmi les palestiniens
georges habache renoue avec yasser
arafat ces chefs d'état présents ont
décidé la création d'un comité de
liaison politique et d'information tous
les membres du front de la fermeté ils
se rencontreront régulièrement pour
étudier l'évolution de la situation au
proche orient après l'initiative du
président cada par ailleurs les liens
entre les syriens et palestiniens vont
se raffermir le front a décidé la
création des caisses financement qui
aidera à l'ulb et la syrie à faire face
à leurs besoins financiers notamment
pour l'achat d'armements
la météo en france un léger mieux en
montagne aujourd'hui un temps froid et
sec est revenu sur les alpes où je vous
le rappelle les avalanches ont fait ces
dernières heures 15 morts le ciel s'est
dégagé donc pour l'instant mais les
spécialistes de la météo sont quand même
un peu inquiet car un radoucissement est
encore possible demain ainsi que de
nouvelles chutes de neige en particulier
sur la savoie la situation selon la
préfecture de chambéry est ce soir
parfaitement maîtrisée en savoie aucune
station aucun mot net isolé dans ce
département de nombreuses routes sont
encore coupées par des coulées de neige
des déviations ont été mises en place et
la circulation partiellement rétablis
par mesure de sécurité toutefois
certaines routes menacés par de
nouvelles avalanches seront interdites
de nuit à la circulation notamment dans
la vallée des belleville et en maurienne
haute savoie la situation demeure
préoccupante
bien que le froid et le sexe soit
installé diminuant les risques
d'avalanche qu'on attend de nouvelles
chutes de neige pour demain il en est
tombé 1 m en 24 heures dans la vallée de
chamonix qui abrite l'hiver plus de
trente mille personnes et où l'on
dénombre sens couloirs avalancheux des
chalets des colonies de vacances ont été
évacués
le ski des conseillers dans certaines
stations en sondant la neige les
sauveteurs recherchent toujours les
disparus l'espoir de retrouver des
survivants s'amenuise
certaines avalanches qui ont déferlé des
sommets dans ces régions de savoie ou de
votre savoir atteignait une largeur de
800 mètres et une épaisseur de près de
10 m
voilà ça nous amène directement à la
météo pour demain dimanche les pluies ou
des averses vont se produire dans la
plupart des régions il va neiger sur
l'est et le nord-est de la france ainsi
qu'en montagne en particulier sur le
jura les pyrénées et les alpes
donc une nouvelle fois des risques
d'avalanche dans les pyrénées et les
alpes en cours d'après-midi sur la
moitié ouest du pays et dans le midi
méditerranéen éclaircies passagères avec
des vents de nord ouest assez fort
les rafales près du golfe du lion avant
de terminer ce journal une dernière
information concernant le cosmos 954 ce
satellite soviétique qui a cessé
d'exister
c'est l'expression employée par les
soviétiques au dessus du canada
il y avait à bord je vous le rappel de
l'uranium ordinaire enrichi l'accident
de ce cosmos 954 serait due d'après
l'académicien soviétique saidov à une
collision avec un corps naturel ou
artificiel dit l'académicien
d'autre part les yeux les soviétiques
n'avaient pas prévenu le canada parce
qu'il pensait tout simplement que le
satellite allait tomber non pas sur le
canada mais sur les états unis
hervé claude frappe prépare déjà la
dernière édition du journal qu'il vous
présentera vers 23h40 juste après la
remise des césars donc je vous souhaite
une très belle soirée sur antenne 2
à